Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata. Siamo arrivati
a Febbraio e una delle cose che più
parla secondo me di carnevale, in generale
di questo periodo, sono le frappe,
chiacchiere e vabbè fatemi sapere come
le chiamate, perché hanno sempre nomi
diversi a seconda di come ti muovi
Qual'è però la svolta che voglio offrire a tutti quanti voi. Che oggi si faremo delle frappe, chiacchiere
Inventa, conia un altro termine (Chef Rico)
Sbrenfe. Qual'è però il piccolo twist di oggi, che si, faremo delle sbrenfe per carnevale
ma le faremo al microonde in tre minuti, velocissime
Per fare le sbrenfe al microonde... C'è qualcuno che sta pisciando
Arriverà lo scarico a breve. L'abbiamo inibito, adesso avrà una vescica "così"
Grazie Chef Mario. Dicevo, avremo bisogno di
farina, zucchero, latte, uno zitrone che
abbiamo qui dai secoli, uno zombie. Lievito, vanillina,
burro, un uovo, dell'olio, zucchero a velo
per spolverare un pochino e della grappa,
da bere per dimenticare
Partiamo subito col procedimento, ma
prima indossiamo il mio meraviglioso grembiule
Prima di tutto vorrei ringraziare atuttomicroonde.net, che ha ispirato
diciamo questa ricetta,
quindi se, grazie atuttomicroondepunto.net
che altro dire,
Speriamo che funzioni. Zucchero e uovo
75 grammi di zucchero...aggiungiamo l'uovo
E arriminiamola. Ok
Raccogli in un angolo, premi il cosino sopra.
Peso al volo il burro
Un piattino m'hai dato un ufo
Ringraziamo Chef Mario (Chef Rico)
Grazie Chef Mario per la tua umiltà
Prendiamo 50 g di burro nel frattempo e buttiamoli nel microonde per 45 secondi
Ok. 50 grammi di latte
Stai mbriaco dopo ste frappe (Chef Mario)
50 grammi di grappa, mammamia...Vanillina, mezza bustina
di lievito per dolci. Come faccio a capire a fare mezza bustina? Con l'unico metodo
Secondo me, un pò du più
Quindi alla fine hai fatto a occhio (Chef Rico)
A occhio. Sta buccia di limone grattugiato che è
stato grattuggiato da chiunque
Sto grattuggiando tutte le superfici che rimangono di sto limone... e rimane tutta qua
E' alcolico. Iniziamo ad aggiungere la
farina
Ma scusa ma le sbrenfe so alcoliche ? (Chef Rico)
Le chiameremo sbornie . So 400 grammi de farina
E' storto il plasticone (Chef Mario)
E adesso aggiungiamo pian
piano 400 grammi di farina, che me sembrano no svario
Ok. Certo noi na planetaria no eh? Alle
nonne, che facevano tutto quanto...con l'amore
Si, ecco
Mamma mia Guglielmo (Chef Rico)
Succede sempre, succede sempre, succede
la farina non bisogna leccarla. Oddio
Mi tiri su qua? Non so cosa fare. Sono, sono, in questo momento sono nel panico
No Guglielmo! (Chef Rico)
Tocca. L'impasto è strano,
non mi, non mi torna sotto molti punti di
vista, sa che lo dovevo lavorare di più e già mi ero stancato. Qua dicono di avvolgerlo, cioè di
di rimetterlo la dentro e avvolgerlo con un
panno umido. Io non c'ho tempo pe ste cose
ragazzi, del panno umido, cioè con
affetto, dai. Che mo deve lievitare? Amen
Aspetta...Abbiamo finito di impastare,
mettiamolo dentro... Ohh ok, è fatto ragazzi
Ti prego stenditi, sei troppo elastico
Eh perché forse non ha lievitato (Chef Rico)
Ma manco dieci minuti? Fallo respirà un attimo sto coso (Chef Mario)
Si questo è un chiacchierone Gu (Chef Rico)
Questo qui sono la maggior parte delle persone che conosco
Non sono veramente preciso ragazzi
scusatemi
Ok, piazzato qui. A sta botta è andata così, lo so usare
Ok, forse abbiamo avuto dei problemi di
audio, possiamo dirlo?
No forse senza forse (Chef Rico)
Abbiamo avuto dei problemi di audio?
Forse (Chef Rico)
Chiediamo scusa. Quando le cose sembrano
andar bene c'è sempre un modo in cui la
vita te lo mette al c***.
Ragazzi siamo in un momento di difficoltà, ci si sono
scaricate le batterie, quindi purtroppo
per questo video di carnevale avrete un audio di m***a
Scherzo di Aprile (Chef Rico)
Ma perché non le friggi direttamente, ma quanto pensi di metterci? Meno di 4 ore al microonde (Chef Mario)
Tu sei pazzo. A me non mi va
Rega sta fumando qualcosa(Chef Rico) che succede è
Che succede?
Eh qualcosa è nero lì (Chef Rico)
Si, qualcosa sta bruciando. Tanti auguri a me
Mamma mia Gu (Chef Rico)
Copriamo, copriamo, copriamo... E queste sono le nostre "Sbrenfe"
Che dire, l'aspetto è abominevole,
è quello di un figlio che non hai mai voluto
l'odore è quello di un figlio che hai voluto
Non penso sia commestibile Gu (Chef Rico)
Il sapore è quello dei bambini, non è male
Sono mortificato, vi chiedo scusa per
aver rubato minuti preziosi della vostra vita
atuttomicroonde ma mi spieghi cosa ho
sbagliato esattamente?
Le dosi, montato a neve, montato bianco, messo il burro
sciolto, messo la vanillina. Cioè chi c***o mette più la
vanillina e ce l'ho messa comunque, la
grappa c'ho messo. E questo è quello che ho?
Questo fuma ancora. Mamma mia sembrano quasi zombie
Sono belle da vedere. Chernobyl
Guglielmo, non se ne può più...ad assaggiare...è un chewingum
Esci tipo... Guarda... Vabbè ho capito basta, basta! Non fa bene. E no che non fa bene ma
pensì che a me faccia bene questo commento?
Basta, avete stancato. Niente ragazzi ci
vediamo ci vediamo, la prossima
settimana
Ciao